welcome to day three of our workshop
i'm going to introduce eran zubag who's
going to talk about
optimization of full rsb spherical spin
glasses
um from weissman and i've been wanting
to learn about this stuff for a long
time
so take it away eileen thank you chris
and thank you for the organizers of the
invitation
i'm going to talk about a certain
optimization problem in a setting
somewhat similar to ahmed stoke but in
the spherical case
and i want to start with the pure models
so these are not exactly the models
i will talk about the term will not be
on these models but these are good for
motivation
and these are simply uh homogeneous
polynomials
in n variables x1 to xn
uh and i'm going to make a distinction
between
degree equal to p equal 2 and p louder
or equal to 3.
and in both cases you just define the
random function in rn by
you go over or monomials of this degree
and you multiply each of them
by an iid gaussian and you sum
so basically that's the the most basic
way to define a
random function in high dimensions
and since these are homogeneous
functions it's enough to understand them
on the sphere
in the unit sphere and what i'm
interested in is the question of uh
efficient optimization of such function
honestly
and more precisely what i want to know
is whether there exists
an algorithm which takes as an input all
the coefficients j
it outputs a point on the sphere such
that for any small epsilon
the value at the output is the maximum
up to multiplicative error of epsilon
the probability that it goes to one
and we want to do it in time complexity
which is polynomial in
n for the sake of comparison if you just
want to
exhaustively search for such a point to
get an epsilon error you need
exponentially many samples
and of course the case where the degree
is 2 is 3vr because
you just need to understand the matrix
this you can take the symmetric part of
this matrix j
and you can just look at the egg and
decomposition of this
matrix and everything would be
clear from that and any silly algorithm
will work for example
how iteration works in this case
and in the case for p is outer than
three what we believe is
that there is no such algorithm i'll
talk
later about some hardness results but of
course we don't have
results that cover all algorithms
and the caricature is more or less this
if you look at the function in the case
of p is equal to 2
i just plot the function such that the
distance from the origin
is the value at the point on the sphere
this is how it looks in the case where p
equal to
and when p is larger than 3 it's a much
more complex function
and specifically it has many more
critical points so
in the case in the case of p is equal to
2 you have
the critical points are just the
eigenvectors and they come in pairs on
the sphere so if
v is a negative vector minus v is also
an eigenvector
with probability one you have exactly n
such spells and only one of them
correspond to a local maxi
so roughly speaking although not
technically but this is roughly a
convex optimization problem because you
only have one local maximum
and in the case of p is larger than 3 we
know that they are exponentially in n
many local maxima most of them the value
at most of them would be far from the
global maximum
uh this was proved in expectation by
two core figures and engine cherny
he computed the expected number of local
maxima or
points of any other index at a given
height in expectation
and my contribution was to show
using a second moment computation that
there is concentration
around the expectation
okay so i told you about uh two problems
one is trivial when p is equal to two
and
the other we assume is too difficult to
really optimize and
i wanna talk about positive results in
this talk about
cases where you can optimize for this i
want to consider
a more general class of models these are
called the
mixed bispin models in physics
and they are simply linear combinations
of the pure models
here the c the coefficients c i are just
deterministic
uh numbers that determine your problem
and the game is as before we take n to
infinity
we get as an input the coefficient from
all of these polynomials
and we want to produce a point close to
the max
just as an example i'll talk about this
situation soon we should expect to
optimize at least when
c2 is very large compared to the other
score
to the other coefficients because in
this case
most of the weight is on the easy
problem so
if if c is 2 is very large and all the
other coefficients are tiny
you should expect to be able to say
something
okay and here's the main theorem i want
to talk about
so i need to assume a certain condition
i need to assume that the support of the
palliative measure at zero temperature
is the interval zero one and
i will not define what this means
exactly
but i will tell you what it implies in
terms of the
some geometric properties of the
function h n
and also this condition is equivalent to
an explicit condition
in terms of those coefficients c you
just
obstruct this polynomial in one variable
a deterministic polynomial
nu which is called a mixture and you
check whether this condition holds
whether this
function here is concave on the interval
if you don't know anything about spin
glasses you can just
replace this condition by this explicit
condition and get the theorem that
doesn't uh require any knowledge about
spin losses
and under this assumption what we have
is that for any epsilon
there's an algorithm with complexity
constantly depends on epsilon times n to
the p
which outputs a point on the sphere
which is maximal up to this
epsilon error
just a small remark about the complexity
the number of coefficients you have in
the definition of h
n is of the order of the number of
coefficients of
h and p which is exactly n to the p so
your input
is of this orders and you cannot expect
to do any better than this
this is the minimal complexity
and
okay so just to give you some feel about
what this condition means
first if you just do the compute it's uh
it's a simple problem to understand when
it when it holds but
uh so just some algebra but
if you check it you'll see that this
condition never holds if c2 is equal to
zero
so need some weight on the easy problem
and if c2 and c3 are positive but
all the other ones are zero then still
you cannot solve this problem even if c2
is huge and c3 is tiny
and moreover in the last case well you
have a positive c2
and another cons another ci which is
positive for
i larger than 4. if you fix the
coefficient c3 to cp
it will determine the certain threshold
and this condition
will hold if and only if c2 is larger
than this threshold
okay so we so essentially we can solve
the problem in the situation said before
when c2 is loud enough
and i want to mention
a similar result in the in the easing
case
so this is actually two results the
first is by andrea
uh essentially immediately after this
result
and uh andrea andreas result is about
the sk model so this is for optimization
uh over the hypercube we call it easing
spins
uh specifically for the case where
h the pure case with p equal to that's
the sk model
uh and more recently ahmed andrea
and mark sanchez proved a more general
result
which allows you to prove under this
assumption
about the support of the policy measure
allows you
it shows that you can optimize using
certain amp algorithms
and regarding negative results
so in the same work they show that they
get uh
they show that the energy that until
which you can optimize
or the best mp algorithm will produce a
certain energy which
they write as a certain variational
problem and you need to check whether it
matches
the progressive formula for the maximum
energy
and if not then i'll go with any any
amp algorithm will fail in the sense
that i would hear any algorithm
will produce a point which would be
smaller than a fraction of the maximum
and also the the result by david and
orchestra
about mp in the pure p spin model
uh would be even louder than four
uh and an even more recent result
together with alex one they showed that
low degree polynomials
for the same orders
okay so for the rest of the talk i want
to
explain tell you what the algorithm is
and
show you how it naturally arises from
some properties
and the first thing i want to show you
to tell you about is this ultrametric
tree which is a famous result in spin
glasses
and what it says is that
not necessarily assuming the full rsp uh
that the condition i had about the
parisi measure
for any model or any generic models
with probability it goes to one there
exists a tree
with some properties and this tree is
its vertices are uh points in the bowl
in the unit ball specifically the root
is at the origin and the leaves
are points on the sphere of radius one
and the first property it has is that
any two
edges on this three are orthogonal
so that's a geometric property of the
tree
and the second property is maximality of
the energy
so again for any now for any vertex on
the tree
the energy at the vertex properly
normalized by n
is equal to the maximal energy over the
corresponding sphere the sphere of the
same radius
up to small levels
and lastly and this is the relation to
the palliative particle measure
this the number of levels on this tree
depends on the size of the support of
the parisi measure
in the so-called klsb situation we have
a
tree of depth k and in this situation
i'm interested in
where the support is the interval 0 1
the number of levels will go to
infinity as n goes to infinity and
asymptotically we'll have vertices
at any radius between 0 and 1. so
what you should imagine is essentially a
continuous object
in the limit it has this nice
orthogonality property
and more and the second
property which would be very important
for optimization is that
over this used structure the energy is
consistently maximum
and what the algorithm will do is
try to use this um information
let me just remark that what we want is
one of the orange points the points on
the sphere of radius one
and we're going to use the structure of
this street to get to one of them
okay of course the fact that this three
exists doesn't help me directly i can't
just uh my algorithm cannot pick a point
from between
because this tree is random
quick question so this tree has this
tree has n
vertices or n plus one vertices
no the number of you mean you're talking
about
bounds because of the fact that the
edges are orthogonal
because of the dimensionality right
then so
you can take the number of vertices on
the tree to go to infinity
slowly with n and
if i because of this orthogonality
property
of course i can't stick too many points
with this orthogonality and dimensions
i thought i thought in ahmed's talk he
said he
gave the weaker property that each edge
is orthogonal to
the previous edges on the path from it
to the root
but you're saying that all of the edges
are mutually orthogonal
yes
yes
but but what i need to use is just 3
which is
infinite in the limit so for me any
number that goes to infinity with n is
okay
um this construction follows from the
famous autometricity
uh property that dimitri pacheco po
and the maximality here is a more recent
result from a work i have
related to the top approach
so okay elliran if so if i might follow
up
on chris question so should i think of
this as a double limit
that first i take n to infinity and the
number of
branches in the tree is fixed and then i
take the number of branches
larger and larger and then there is the
near orthogonality
and near maximality maybe orthogonality
and near maximality exactly
you should think you can think of fixed
k for the number of vertices
and then take k to infinity after n goes
to infinity
um okay
so now i want to look at one pad from
this tree
and just it will inherit the same
properties
you just saw but i want to make it
explicit so
i take a path from this tree and it's
essentially
technically it's discrete so i'm going
to interpolate it
linearly between the points the number
of uh
segments on this path will go to
infinity as an goes to infinity in
in the full rsv case uh and i
interpolate it so that
at time q uh the radius
is squared q
and because of the orthogonality on the
tree
for this path any segment is going to be
orthogonal to the current position
because
orthogonal to our previous segments
and it also has this uh
controllable the energy the energy is
consistently maximal in the
in this sense it's uh just the maximal
energy of on the corresponding radius
now what i want to do is forget about
the ultrametric tree and think of how i
can construct such a path by myself
okay so so assume that somebody tells
you in the full rsp we have
many paths like this now what you need
to think of is how you would construct
such a path
by yourself with these two properties
the first property we can just impose so
just create this path by concatenating
many directions which we force to be
orthogonal at each point
the current position so i'm thinking of
choosing them iteratively
and at each step i'm going to take them
to be orthogonal
to the current position
what i need to understand now is how i
choose them so that i
maximize the energy at this step
we know that we also maximize it locally
so the algorithm should choose
locally now
the first observation you should make is
that if you can't construct this path
up to time i what should happen is that
you'll end up with a point at which the
energy is maximal
therefore the gradient on the orthogonal
space should be zero because
you're at the maximal energy on the
corresponding sphere
therefore the gradient of the sphere and
also in our end on the orthogonal plane
is going to be roughly zero
so we can't use the gradient and the
second best
so so we need to increase the
approximation to a second-order
approximation
sorry and what we're going to do is just
go in a direction which correspond to
one of the large eigenvalues of the
hessian
restricted to the tangent space okay so
any anything in the span of the large
eigenvalues eigenvectors corresponding
to the loudest eigenvalues we walk
so here's the algorithm explicitly
i fix some number of steps k which is
going to be large
and some small delta which would be an
arrow which i'll allow
which you see in a second and i
as you remember i construct the path
from the origin outside so i initialize
the origin and at each iteration i'm
going to choose a direction
a vector of length one which is
orthogonal to my current position
for simplicity i will also take it to be
orthogonal to the gradient
we know that the gradient is supposed to
be zero so i might as well take it
orthogonal
now i want and this is the important
thing i want the
second order term in a taylor expansion
around my
location to be almost maximal
overall use which satisfy these
constraints
you can use the delta and then simply
take a small step in this direction
the size of the step is such that after
k steps you'll end up exactly on the
sphere of radius
one okay this is v is orthogonal to x i
so it's clear how the
radius goes
and what you can check is that the
energy on this path
with high probability will be maximal as
we want
up to an arrow epsilon which is as small
as we wish
provided k is large and delta is small
i will tell you in a second why the two
you can also check that the complexity
of each iterate is
some constant that depends on delta and
the size of your input
all the the complexity is essentially of
computing the this uh
action and then you just do power
iteration to get the vector
to get the vector v just do power
iteration on the orthogonal space
this will be enough because we only need
to find v
with delta l
and the last thing i want to tell you
about is the proof because it's quite
easy if you
once you have all the insights and you
realize what the algorith
the right algorithm should be the proof
is uh quite simple
and it goes like this so i have this
path which is by itself random and i
want to control
the energy on this path which sounds
like bad news
but it's not because for these models we
can actually control the hessian
uniformly over the ball in the sense
in not a very strong sense but enough
for what we need
the statement is that with high
probability
for all the points in the ball look at
the edge
of the spectrum of this hessian it will
roughly be
this specific value this function nu
is the mixture it was constructed from
the coefficients in the
linear combinations of the pure models
so that's an explicit function that is
determined
by the problem and then if i want to
understand how the energy
evolves at each step i just tell or
expand
and so this is the zero order term the
energy
at the point i'm at the set the first
order term will
vanish because we are choosing a
direction orthogonal to the gradient
and the second term is exactly what we
get from this proposition
and the third order term the arrow term
will be
of smaller order in k and as you take k
to infinity what you'll get
is just an approximation of this riemann
integral
and so this is the energy for this path
and actually from the parisi formula
we know that for models where the
progressive measure
is the zero one interval you can just
plug it into the policy formula and get
the value of the maximum
and this is exactly this value
and that's what i wanted to say
uh so if it's not a full support
so that does that mean that mu of q at
some point is zero so that you don't
gain
an increment in the energy with this
orthogonal move is that
so that the algorithm gets stuck in a
sense is that what happens when
there's a gap no so what happens is that
for
any model the energy i wrote here is the
energy you get with this algorithm
or any without any assumption because
this
opposition is general so just apply it
for any
model and this is what you get but for
any model
which for which this new double prime to
the minus f is not concave
this will not be the right energy
so for example in the pure case what
will happen is that you get to
the energy uh
where you start to see local maxima
so you'll you'll achieve the energy this
the same kind of thing that ahmed told
us where you achieve the energy
corresponding to the
the optimal uh monotone function u
so in the spherical case the uh
the best achievable value uh
with amp from the work of ahmed er
andrea and
mark is exactly this value the spherical
case you can just solve the
uh variational problem and this is what
you get so this is the
the same as the best mpa algorithm
thank you very much so we have time for
some questions i'm
watching the chat and the q a on zoom
i don't see questions coming in just yet
any questions from anyone
i'll ask a trivial question just to make
sure i'm following in the pure case
uh all the spheres are the like inside
spheres are the same right
i mean this maximality property that's
right yes okay just to make sure i
checked got it
also i mean i can ask uh how much does
it rely on the coefficients being
gaussian like does it also
uh something similar work for
non-gaussian other distribution
coefficients i assume that yes i didn't
check but
you need to verify that this proposition
holds the other universality results for
for the police formula so this part is
okay
and yes i think yes because
you don't need too much about uh
you don't need i mean for the uniform
result i'm using some bounds
which require large deviations for the
empirical measure of the
of the spectrum of a goe matrix we need
something to substitute for this
to get to to be able to to have uniform
bounds
of the entire ball uh and i'm not sure
for which matrices we have this okay but
probably for like some reasonable
coefficient distributions it should be
fine
yes
[Music]
so a comment there is that for so the
large deviation principle you only need
the speed to be n squared you don't care
about the rate function
right the rate function will not be
universal but the speed will be
universal
right you're right i don't i don't use
the full uh large deviation principle i
only use
the fact that events
on the order of the empirical measure
happen with
speed that is larger than n anything
larger than n
for this event for events of this type
would be sufficient
yeah but isn't there something a little
bit tricky
you know it's sure that this works but
you know the action
in the in the gaussian case the action
is a goe matrix
in the non-garcian case i think the
ashen doesn't have iid entries
does it because in the
in i think in the gaussian case you are
using the fact that if you rotate
a g o e you get a g if you rotate a
matrix a digital matrix you don't
yeah see right so but yeah i mean it
should work
yeah i don't have an immediate answer
for this but uh
yes but maybe you can control
yes any other questions for iran
i'll go ahead david yeah uh this is
marginally related but
what's known about if the
the the concavity is for the pairwise
overlap support
right uh that's supposed to describe
also the pairwise overlap is what's
known about multi-overlap support so if
i take many replicas in
spherical models and i look at the
matrix of overlaps it's supposed to span
the entire cube or when when the
pairwise overlap
is described by concave function or
there's something
more intricate yeah for any
for generic models uh the
the prism is there the distribution of
the
just a pair of overlaps determines the
this array of all overlaps
and it will be the same as a
well probability some some structure
that
with the corresponding distribution so
this distribution actually determines
the whole
distribution of the whole array that's
right it does determine
determined because of the gaussianity
which just depends on the covariances
but uh what's what's known about this
multi-overlap
the support of the multi-overlap
distribution is it just a cube or
could it be more complicated than you
mean in the spherical case
let's say in the spherical case let's
say in the concave when the
overlapped second derivative square root
is concave
in in your setting so any so if you're
in the fuller sp case anything that
satisfies ultrametricity is okay
any any any array of all the overlaps
that
that respects ultrametricity can be
sampled
okay multi ashi okay good
and then we also have the this is
essentially so this follows from the
land aguero and
automaticity we have an explicit uh
description for the whole uh or the
distribution of this array
with probability okay
thanks
i'll just ask like one more question as
like a dumb guy that doesn't follow
these things too much
uh so if i understand correctly like the
the ultra matricity result in the tree
this is all like inspiration and like in
the end
like the only thing that you kind of use
from
uh this body of knowledge is the pre-z
formula right here on the slide
yes you can also
you can also even if you
there is a way to prove this even
without the policy formula if you assume
some structural thing from the three you
can actually uh
avoid using the policy formula
like you know you could use a previously
formula but what's the other thing i
mean there's something else you can do
yeah that's why i wrote it actually
because there is a
because you can you can use
ultrametricity
directly as a property and and get
and and and there's a geometric
explanation why this actually has to be
the value
without actually appealing to this
formula
but it does require ultrametricity which
is a heavy result
but is that easier to i mean i guess
it's easier to prove
what automaticity yeah not really
okay they're all hard yeah okay
um maybe i can ask this is just
wondering so does it make sense to ask a
similar
question in the context of slightly more
complicated models like
pot spin glasses and stuff and and what
should be expected in these settings
i have i don't have a good answer but
except for when you can analyze
so when you can analyze that the top
approach properly and you have ultra
metricity
then what should happen is
so this property of the three
for example in the easing case its
maximality is replaced by
a maximum instead of the energy of
on both sides you should add a tab
correction so some deterministic
function which
i will not explain what it is but
in the easy case this is what will be
maximized over the tree
and i think that this is more general
but for example when you have
automaticity
there should be something like this
hiding
but i don't have a most
refined statement of this
okay so how about we take a five-minute
break
and we'll come back at 9 40 for pacific
time for stefano
uh stefano's talk stefano sarah
almanelli
so thank you very much let's thank elron
again